lightyear is an origin story for the
character behind the buzz lightyear toy
from the toy story series so there are
plenty of franchise referencing easter
eggs in disney pixar's latest where have
we heard the phrase crystalic fusion
before and why was that zerg battle so
familiar keep watching to find out
you can't separate buzz lightyear from
his space ranger suit quite literally in
the toy story movies even though he gets
some time out of the bubble helmet and
lightyear buzz still seems the most like
himself when he's geared up in the green
galactic alliance garb there are a
couple of different iterations of the
space ranger suit that pop up throughout
light year with the old school model
from the beginning and the updated
version in the final scenes being the
two main ones they both include a lot of
little details that are pulled straight
out of toy story that long time fans
will surely catch from the three
brightly colored buttons on buzz's chest
plate to the wrist communicator he's
constantly talking into the lightyear
suit is a spot on recreation of the toy
or at least the new model scene at the
end of the movie is the older suits have
some small differences no wrist laser
and a big red button instead of a switch
on the front revealed to be the shameful
surrender button but by the time the
credits roll buzz and his team have all
gotten their shiny new space ranger
outfits a design so cool that every kid
in 1995 wanted to have one of their own
a lot of the story in lightyear centers
around crystalic fusion the sci-fi
method by which star command and its
agents are able to achieve hyperspeed
when buzz and the other inhabitants of
the star command ship crash land at the
start of the film their old fusion core
is destroyed forcing them to experiment
with the resources available to them
locally in the hopes of creating a new
one it's a process that takes decades
with buzz undergoing numerous failed
experiments with crystals that are just
a little bit off finally his robot
companion socks comes up with the
correct solution and a fully functional
crystalic fusion core is created of
course crystallic fusion has been a part
of toy story lore from the very
beginning in the original film during
buzz and woody's very first conversation
buzz asks his future best friend a
series of questions believing himself to
have landed on an alien planet in the
hope of repairing his ship he asks woody
what power sources are available people
still use fossil fuels or have you
discovered crystallic fusion well let's
see we got double a's in the grand
scheme of things this is a tiny detail
buried in a throwaway line so it's cool
to see lightyear remain so loyal to the
idea in its own story
there are a lot of lines in lightyear
that are taken straight out of the toy
story movies like a lot some of them
will be immediately obvious to anyone
familiar with the earlier movies for
instance at the very beginning of light
year when buzz and alicia are exploring
the alien planet buzz records a mission
log commenting on the landscape
observing that the terrain seems a bit
unstable of course this is also his
comment when walking around on andy's
bed in the original toy story
[Music]
terrain seems a bit unstable
there are a bunch of callbacks like this
scattered throughout light year classics
like i'm buzz lightyear i'm always sure
and not today zerg add a nice texture to
the film by connecting it repeatedly
back to toy story it's fun to see all
the little ways in which the toy buzz
pulls his personality from his fictional
self and the many catch phrases are a
great way of showing that
the first act of light year is a roller
coaster to say the least after crashing
on the alien planet and setting up a
colony buzz and star command begin
working on a new crystalic fusion core
to reactivate hyperspeed and get
everybody off world buzz flies the first
test mission for the core which is
supposed to take him four minutes and 28
seconds however due to the temporal
distortion of hyperspeed more than four
years have passed by the time buzz lands
time dilation is certainly not a new
concept in the sci-fi genre but in the
modern context of the genre it's hard
not to draw a direct comparison to
christopher nolan's interstellar which
features a devastating moment of severe
time dilation buzz's four years aren't
nearly as long as the amount of time
skipped an interstellar but the effect
is still unnerving what's arguably even
more unsettling is that buzz continues
to volunteer for more test flights
knowing full well that he'll lose years
every time
despite the fact that his voice actor
anatomy and universe are all completely
different buzz himself stays remarkably
consistent to his toy story
characterization and lightyear some of
his personality traits are obvious the
need to constantly record his mission
log his wariness and his hyper fixation
on the mission at hand but some of the
other consistencies are much smaller and
easier to miss for instance buzz's
resistance to teamwork and specifically
to working with anyone he deems
unqualified is very true to his
portrayal in the first toy story in fact
he experiences very similar arcs in the
two films going from a moody loner to a
willing member of a larger community
buzz's general hesitation at normal
social interaction and relationship
building is also something that's kept
the same from toy story as the character
is always more focused on his mission in
both instances by keeping all these
little personality touches the same
pixar pulls off an impressive balancing
act creating a version of the character
who feels new while at the same time
being a continuation of what's been
established in the past
the opening of light years says that it
was released in 1995 in the toy story
timeline while it would have been easy
for the film to completely ignore that
detail later on it remains an active
component of the overarching style a lot
of the movie takes inspiration from even
older sci-fi franchises like buck rogers
but there are a number of details that
feel specifically 90s in nature during
buzz's first hyper-speed test flight for
example his autopilot system ivan starts
malfunctioning buzz pulls ivan out of
the ship system revealing it to be
nothing more than a blocky plug-in and
blows into it like it's an nes cartridge
sure enough the autopilot immediately
starts to work as intended this isn't
the only 90s detail that comes up either
many of the digital readouts in light
year have the blocky overlays of 90s
computer screens which makes sense for a
movie that's supposed to have been
released in 1995. obviously lightyear
pulls from all eras of science fiction
and it still feels like a contemporary
animated movie in its overall structure
but still it's fun to see that the
writers committed to the mid-1990s
setting in multiple ways
when you make a big budget science
fiction movie it's only right that you
pay homage to the greats of the genre
lightyear takes that obligation quite
seriously and one of its most clever
sci-fi references is to none other than
stanley kubrick's 2001 a space odyssey
open the pod bay doors hell after things
go wrong on his first hyperspeed test
flight buzz frantically tries to get his
ship back to the ground in one piece
unfortunately his autopilot ivan is more
of a hindrance than a help in a fit of
frustration buzz shouts the order open
the fuel door ivan the computer responds
i'm sorry i didn't quite catch that a
clear parody of how
i'm sorry dave
i'm afraid i can't do that not only is
this a sneaky reference to 2001 but it's
also a joke about how siri and other
real world voice command and navigation
systems often mishear things this isn't
the first time that buzz lightyear has
been part of a 2001 easter egg in the
opening sequence of toy story 2 which is
set in a video game starring the space
ranger the film's iconic theme music is
played via a series of floating
platforms clearly someone at pixar has a
lot of love for 2001
it's no secret that pixar loves spoofing
star wars in its buzz lightyear story
lines zerg is basically a big silly
purple darth vader with emperor
palpatine's title and if you thought
that light year would mark the end of
buzz's history of star wars references
you'd be very wrong the big one in light
year is more subtle than some of the
ones in the toy story films but it
should still stick out to those who know
both series well sox buzz's robotic cat
comrade is able to interface with
various computer systems using a plug in
the tip of his tail when he interfaces
and starts hacking his head spins around
in full 360 degrees and he starts
mumbling beep boop beep boop over and
over again it's a funny gag if a pretty
simple one and it seems like a pretty
clear reference to r2d2's own hacking
habits in star wars
as the toy story movies constantly
remind us buzz lightyear is a cool toy
he comes with karate chop action a wrist
mounted laser and a winged jet pack all
of these special abilities come into
play in light year as well with some
proving crucial at multiple points
throughout the film buzz shows off his
karate chop action which manifests as a
far more versatile collection of martial
arts skills his wrist laser doesn't come
with the old space ranger suit model but
in the third act of the film buzz
improvises by strapping a smaller
standalone laser blaster to his wrist
for easy use the weapon comes in handy
in his battle with zerg and when the new
space ranger suits are revealed at the
end of the film they all have wrist
lasers built in as for buzz's winged
jetpack pixar waits most of the movie to
reveal it only when the rest of the team
is re-entering the atmosphere in their
ship does buzz pop the wings to try to
help keep the vessel on course it all
works out though the re-entry could
definitely be classified as falling with
style your mark
yeah but in a supportive way
light year wouldn't be complete without
a proper battle between buzz and zerg
and that's exactly what the film
delivers in its third act the two go
head-to-head in a heated fight that
spans zerg's dreadnought and even
extends to the open space beneath it
with buzz ultimately coming out
victorious while not a carbon copy the
lightyear fight does have some
similarities to the zurich battles in
the toy story movies for instance the
shot where buzz jumps and front flips
over zerg then turns to quickly fire a
laser back is taken right out of the
buzz lightyear video game rex plays at
the beginning of toy story 2.
fortunately the real buzz has better
luck than rex and of course the last
round of the rival's duel in light year
which takes place in the void of space
features a classic exchange between the
two zerg orders buzz to prepare to die
and buzz retorts not today zerg we all
knew it was coming but it's still fun to
hear
the ending of light year foreshadows a
bright future for buzz his friends and
the galactic alliance the space ranger
core is reinstated with state-of-the-art
tech and buzz's team becomes officially
sanctioned for high priority missions
their first assignment head to the gamma
quadrant of sector 4 for some
investigating that destination may ring
familiar if you grew up on toy story i'm
stationed up in the gamma quadrant of
sector 4 as a member of the elite
universe protection unit of the space
ranger corps the location is mentioned
again in toy story 2 as it's the setting
of buzz's video game battle with zerg
it's nice to see pixar staying so
consistent with the silly lore they've
created over the decades since the buzz
toy has all the memories of his
fictional self it makes sense that he'd
have a strong association with this
particular locale
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
light year are coming soon subscribe to
our youtube channel and hit the bell so
you don't miss a single one
[Music]